ce sont les techniciens de la sn ds
gestionnaire et c'est d'une société
privée engagée par la ctm propriétaire
de la station de pompage la lézarde
ils sont à pied d'oeuvre depuis la nuit
dernière il s'agit de remettre en état
le circuit endommagée par un incendie
mercredi dernier l'asm e société de
distribution d'eau est en mode veille
plus de 5000 foyers sont impactés par
cette grosse panne les points rouges sur
la carte l'indiquent des anses d'arlet
sainte luce rivière salée du cos
subissent la coupure de plein fouet
on arrive avec des manoeuvres de vannes
à faire passer l'eau d'un bassin versant
à un autre pour essayer de limiter
effectivement les manques d'eau et
répartir l'eau que nous avons mais il
n'en manquera quand même et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a quand même demandé à des
auteurs plus de pompage donc plus
d'arrivée d'eau dans la station de
traitement de directoire station qui
alimente près de 25 mille foyers
rien ne bouge l'activité est à l'arrêt
et même après réparation il faudra user
de patience pour revenir à une
distribution normale
le fait de ne pas avoir cette station à
pleine capacité ça a des conséquences
sur ce qui se passe sous les autres
prestations
donc puisque justement notre réseau et
mallié donc effectivement l'outil par dc
arrive se rajoute à une eau qui vient
d'ailleurs forcément quand cette eau là
n'est pas là bas il ya une forme de
déséquilibre qui se produit sur le
réseau effectivement on peut avoir des
gens qui par exemple à rivière-salée
peuvent être impactés par ce que à
directoire ya un problème bull depuis ce
matin la distribution revient
progressivement chez les abonnés l'asm
elle leur recommande de ne pas faire de
réserve lors de l'arrivée de l'eau car
cela risque de ralentir le processus
normal d'alimentation en eau potable